well one military couple escaped from
Florence just before giving birth
danielle DiGregorio was nine months
pregnant when she and her husband left
Camp Lejeune Marine Corps Base in
Jackson North Carolina well less than 24
hours after arriving in Florida guess
what she went into labor Adriana Diaz is
at Camp Lejeune with that story Adrianna
this is a good story this is a good
story but just take a look at this there
are downed trees throughout Camp Lejeune
and most the base doesn't have power
this is where Danielle do Gregorio was
nine months pregnant awaiting the birth
of her twins last week unfortunately
there was another special delivery
heading here Hurricane Florence so the
military couple tried to outrun the
storm I was like so far along and I was
worried that I wouldn't be able to have
the medical treatment because of the
hurricane
Danielle de Gregorio was 37 weeks
pregnant as hurricane Florence turned
toward her home state she and her
husband saw two options deliver the
twins in a hurricane or make a run for
st. Augustine Florida where their
parents live they went south the drive
was very nerve-racking but it also came
with a relief the closer we got to home
a drive that usually takes about eight
hours took them 12 when we got in the
car I was really praying that I just
made the right choice and everything
would just fall into place and we would
just make it home really safe with our
family and our babies would be okay
their babies held on and less than 24
hours after arriving in st. Augustine
Danielle went into labor
meet Scarlett and Sadie DiGregorio
newborn daughters of a marine who've
already completed a mission they were
supposed to be induced on September 18th
and they came a week early the doctor
thinks is probably because of the
hurricane whatever feeling was probably
the lasagna I ate that night but who
knows what it was I think they were just
ready to come into the world ready to
enter the world surrounded by family
family who wouldn't have been there if
the couple wasn't forced to Florida by
Florence I got to be a part of
everything so I just feel overwhelmed
and blessed it was a big life changer
but I wouldn't change it for anything I
I'm really excited that they're here
it's a handful but you know with
everybody around and the support and we
support each other it's it's been a
great experience so far and I'm just
ready to see where life takes us the
couples from here near Jacksonville
North Carolina they delivered the girls
in Jacksonville Florida they said they
couldn't have done it without the
support of the Marines they plan to
return back here in the next two weeks
but now as an expanded family of four
Nora Wow adriana is a mother of twins I
feel for her just because having twins
is enough having one baby is just enough
to have to flee a storm but the lasagna
I love that side of the story and what
beautiful names
alright Sadie Scarlett and Sadie
Congrats to the parents I've had a lot
of years we'll be sending her lasagna
now I know and gifts yeah that's kind of
your way thanks again for that story